although the witness has been hotly  pirated which is a sore point for  created Jonathan Blow the game is also  selling an awful lot too it seems like  quite a lot of you guys have enjoyed  trading your trusty crosshair for  noodles of puzzles as the gear was  already more profitable than blows last  game grade blur wrote on Twitter that  the witness has generated more revenue  in its first week and Brad did during  its entire first year it's worth noting  that the witness costs forty dollars  while braid was 15 and red launched as  an xbox 360 exclusive hello clarified  the braid may end up selling more copies  than the witness in each games  respective first year but the witness is  leading in revenue he added it's just  great that will be able to make the next  game at a comparable budget level maybe  bigger wall safe let me know if you've  been playing the witness and how you  feel about it for all the latest in  gaming it keep it tuned to games but